[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka guten abend mit
außenministerin baerbock war heute nun
also erstmals ein mitglied der deutschen
bundesregierung kennt kiew sie selbst
hatte keinen hehl daraus gemacht dass er
diese reise schon sehr viel früher
machen wollte aber dann kam die
bekannten kalamitäten um bundespräsident
und bundeskanzler dazwischen
dafür reiste baerbock heute fast schon
als vertreterin der ganzen regierung an
und oder auch vom präsidenten der
ukraine empfangen was protokollarisch
keine selbstverständlichkeit ist das ein
eigentor von dara hassanzadeh haben den
besuch der ministerin in der ukraine
beobachtet
zum abschied ein stadtrundgang durch
kiew oder luftalarm selbst die sie reden
schweigen es sind wohl die ersten
minuten des heutigen tages für annalena
baerbock in denen der krieg nicht
omnipräsent ist
ihr besuch beginnt am morgen mit dem
gedenken der opfer in butter
dort geschah furchtbare kriegsverbrechen
über 400 menschen sollen russische
soldaten getötet haben darunter auch
kinder
und diese opfer auch das spürt man hier
so eindringlich diese opfer könnten wir
sein roger ist ein vorort von kia fußes
wie potsdam vor berlin man sieht
spielplätze man sieht supermärkte man
sieht menschen die zur arbeit gehen und
dann sieht man die schlimmsten spuren
von verbrechen genau daneben
joker tores nakazawa das unh bestrafte
böse wird zynisch anmaßend stark und es
wird weiter machen bis es gestoppt wird
es ist sehr wichtig ist hier zu stoppen
damit der horror der in der ukraine
geschah sich nicht in anderen ländern
wiederholt unter ex-trainer
der burg zeigt offen empathie ihre
nächste station ist ihnen die
ukrainische öffentlichkeit hat sehr wohl
registriert wie deutlich die grüne
außenministerin russland verurteilt sich
für die lieferung von mehr und schweren
waffen einsetzt und die ukraine als ein
teil europas sieht die ukraine ist ein
fester teil europas ich wünschte mir
dass wir auf einen beitrittswunsch eine
starke überzeugende antwort finden auch
wenn es auf dem weg zur eu
vollmitgliedschaft keine abkürzung geben
kann weil etwas nicht noch einmal
passieren kann sind falsche
versprechungen aber ich betone hier ganz
konkret
vollmitgliedschaft auch darüber hat sie
mit präsident selensky gesprochen es sei
ein offenes freundliches treffen gewesen
und sozusagen als gastgeschenk hat der
außenministerin baerbock auch die
wiedereröffnung der deutschen botschaft
angekündigt berbalk ist es heute
gelungen brücken nach kiew zu bauen
kanzler scholz kann sie nun beschreiten
wenn er denn will
katrin eigendorf ist für uns in kiew das
klingt so und das sah auch jetzt so aus
als sei die deutsche außenministerin
trotz all dem hin und her vorher dann
doch jetzt sehr freundlich aufgenommen
worden
ja man weiß hier in kiew durchaus zu
unterschätzen wäre von deutscher seite
hier auftritt und annalena baerbock war
ja von anfang an eine politikerin in
deutschland und das weiß man hier sehr
wohl die russland klar verurteilt hat
die relativ früh auch gesagt hat dass
die ukraine unterstützt werden muss von
deutschland auch mit waffen also hat sie
hier auch jetzt bei diesem besuch einen
neuen ton gesetzt der die beziehungen
glaube ich noch mal auf eine bessere
ebene gehoben hat also sie wurde sowohl
von präsident sie lenski sehr freundlich
empfangen hat aber auch gute gespräche
die wir gehört haben mit ihrem kollegen
kleber geführt was hier gut angekommen
ist ist dass sie auf der einen seite
ziemlich klar position bezogen hat auch
gesagt hat was nicht möglich ist als was
sie als außenministerin natürlich nicht
verantworten kann und beschleunigen kann
und dass sie sich auch sehr empathisch
gezeigt hat also das ist hier einfach
bei den leuten ja sehr hoch angerechnet
wurden dann hat die ukraine aber ja denn
auch forderungen oder erwartungen und
die auch immer wieder enttäuschungen
über deutschland formuliert also
stichwort schwere waffen um muss nur
eines zu nennen
ja diese enttäuschung die werden
sicherlich auch weiter noch in der eu
bei der ukraine fortdauern denn das was
die ukraine sich vorstellt sehr sehr
schnell sehr effiziente
waffenlieferungen um hier diesen krieg
gegen russland möglichst effizient
führen zu können das wird deutschland
nicht erfüllen können das liegt auch
nicht in der macht allein in deutschland
sondern das ist ja im prinzip ja ein
gemeinsames projekt der europäer
daraufhin hat annalena baerbock hier
auch nochmal hingewiesen aber sie hat
auch ganz klar gemacht das hat oberste
priorität für deutschland und das ist
hier auch keine sagen wir mal falschen
kompromisse geben darf in die man die
ukraine drängen sollte jetzt in
irgendein halbherzigen friedensvertrag
mit russland zu gehen sondern das das
ziel sein muss dass die ukraine ein
souveräner staat ist sehr selber über
ihre zukunft entscheiden kann und was
sie auch noch mal klar gemacht hat dass
für deutschland und für sie ganz
besonders die opfer dieses krieges im
mittelpunkt stehen ihre bemühungen das
sie dass deutschland sich da engagieren
will im prinzip auch die ganzen
kriegsverbrechen begangen wurden und
noch immer werden aufzuklären danke für
katrin für diese eindrücke nach kiew
blicken wir auf russland wer andere
länder erobern und deren bevölkerung
unterwerfen oder gar auslöschen will
muss vor allem eines tun dem anderen
staat und dessen volk sein existenzrecht
absprechen das ist eine alte grausame
regel des kolonialismus und
imperialismus auf die aktuell der
historiker und yale professor timothy
snyder verweist die parallelen die
erzieht sind frappierend etwa in der art
und weise wie der kreml die ukraine als
nazis verunglimpft und zugleich verneint
dass die ukraine überhaupt jemals so
etwas wie eine eigene nation war
faktisch falsch historisch falsch aber
es wirkt nicht nur in den köpfen
russischer soldat mit der kunst hat mit
timothy snyder über diese hintergründe
des krieges gesprochen und zeichnet ein
psychogramm des russischen staates unter
poté
ist er krank verrückt geworden unter
medikamenten- oder lesen wir zu viel
hinein in diesen mann den wir uns nicht
mehr erklären können
das erscheint es mir die entwicklung
klassischer tyrannei zu sein in einem
russland mit perfekter ein mann
herrschaft denkt der alternde tyrann
nicht mehr in kategorien wie russische
interessen sondern nur an das eigene
bild für die ewigkeit
der überfall auf die ukraine der
schnelle sieg mit dem putin russische
geschichte schreiben wollte weil seine
armee ins stolpern kam könnte der
präsident bei der parade in moskau
gestern trotz des hurra geschreis
kleinlauter aufgetreten sein als viele
dachten eine generalmobilmachung blieb
aus
nationale russische identität kann gut
mit der zerstörung der ukraine leben
aber die russen weniger gut damit wenn
mehr söhne oder töchter für dieses ziel
sterben müssen
ich glaube bot ihm steckt tatsächlich
fest und in seiner rede gestern hat er
das kriegsziel deshalb auch umdefiniert
jetzt wird der einsatz als kampf gegen
den ganzen westen begriffen vielleicht
als vorbereitung für eine ausrede die
welle es kein krieg nur gegen die
ukraine ist sondern gegen den westen
insgesamt dann ließe sich besser
erklären wenn man am ende konzessionen
machen schätzt geschichte umwidmen
brutal neu definieren das ist die
choreographie eines faschistischen
systems sagt einer der besten kenner der
geschichte russlands und der ukraine
wenn einer als faschist sagt er würde
faschisten bekämpfen wie hier dann
pervertiert er sprache will kategorien
verwischen denn was ist nicht
faschistisch an dieser russischen
regierung wir haben einen
vernichtungskrieg wir haben den versuch
eines genozids wir haben ein führerkult
einen totenkult und einen kult der
vergangenheit als die goldene zeit
eine vergangenheit in der russland immer
die unschuld war die verteidigt werden
musste wie heute
in der speakers to the sun in seiner
rede hat putin wieder gesagt die russen
seien die einzigen die werte bewahren
würden und der westen habe sich
entschieden alle werte zu zerstören
wir haben tatsächlich nicht zugehört
wenn putin über sich selbst geredet hat
wir wollten glauben dass er ein
technokratisch die kategorien aber die
er seit circa 2010 benutzt die von einer
staats die lisa zion in der andere
aufgehen die idee einer russischen
mission außerhalb seiner grenzen
der gedanke dass nur russland die quelle
der erneuerung der zivilisation sein
kann
seit 2010 ist diese ideologie wichtiger
geworden die taktik weniger wichtig
2010 hatte putin als präsident
verfassungsgemäß pausiert aber die macht
behalten und nach der rückkehr ins amt
die zügel festgezurrt
er ist jemand der den westen brechen
wollte lange versucht hat demokratien zu
zerbrechen er war immer gut darin die
schwachpunkte zu finden nicht nur bei
nachbarn auch in europa und den usa ich
glaube er war immer tief überzeugt die
ukraine ist ein witz die europäische
union demokratie alles ein witz
ironischerweise ist das erste das sich
nicht als witz herausstellt
der professor aus yale sagt war echtem
widerstand wisse der präsident in moskau
keine antwort das sei seine schwäche
propaganda wirkt natürlich auch im
freiheitlichen demokratie aber nirgendwo
lässt sie sich so wirksam einsetzen wie
ein autokratien und gar diktaturen und
die mittel ähneln sich immer wieder man
schaue sich etwa dieses propaganda bild
des künftigen philippinischen
machthabers ferdinand marcos junior an
hoch zu ross wie die porträts
mittelalterlicher könige oder heiligen
bildnisse auf diese bildsprache haben in
der gegenwart auch schon wladimir putin
oder nordkoreas kim jong umgesetzt
ausgerechnet der sohn des berüchtigten
ex-diktators markus hat die wahl auf den
philippinen gewonnen der sprössling
dieses unfassbar korrupten familienclans
trägt den spitznamen bonbon und war nach
aussage seines verstorbenen vaters eher
ein sorgenkind faul und leichtsinnig
aber die propaganda im internet
zeitalter funktioniert das weiß bonbon
und voller berichtet über die wahl auf
den philippinen
in der hauptstadt manila gibt es ein
museum das die marcos diktatur verklärt
dort sind tausende von schuhen und
kleidungsstücken der ehemaligen
präsidentengattin imelda marcos
liebevoll ausgestellt ihr lebensstil
symbolisiert die pro zucht und die
korruption des clans der das land um 10
milliarden dollar betrogen haben soll
nie wieder diktatur steht auf den
schildern der protestierenden heute aber
ihre anklage verhallt
[Applaus]
niemand will sich daran erinnern was
damals während der diktatur passiert ist
wir verleugnen die opfer
im leugnen und im vertuschen steht
ferdinand marcos junior seinem vater in
nichts nach der sohn des ehemaligen
diktators hat es geschafft nach einem
wahlkampf voller emotionen hat er den
familien clan der markus wieder an die
macht gebracht
ich erwarte dass eure unterstützung und
euer vertrauen in mich nicht schwinden
denn wir haben uns so viel vorgenommen
für die zukunft nach 20 jahren an der
macht wurde sein vater ende der 80er
jahre von der bevölkerung vertrieben
wegen korruption und
menschenrechtsverletzungen
nun wird sein sohn gefeiert der hat
seinen wahlkampf vor allem im internet
geführt dort hat er die brutale
regierungszeit seines vaters umgedeutet
als glanzvolle epoche der philippinen
die jungen anhänger markus glauben diese
geschichte denn mehr als zehn stunden
täglich sind viele in den sozialen
medien unterwegs sie halten die
verbrechen für erfunden
wenn die vorwürfe gegen den markus klein
war während hätten sich schon viel
früher erhoben werden müssen warum
kommen sie jetzt damit wenn wir die wahl
gewinnen
auch der scheidende präsident dieter
könnte mit dem wahlausgang zufriedener
nicht sein denn er schützt den gegen
juristische verfolgung seinem
erbarmungslosen drogenkrieg fielen
tausende zum opfer seine tochter sarah
soll die vize präsidentin von markus
junior werden beide clans schützen sich
mit ihrer macht vor strafverfolgung
die propaganda ständig erzählt dass es
den philippinen während der markus
regierung besser ging das haben die
wähler irgendwann geglaubt
markus gegner protestieren auf den
straßen von manila sprechen von
wahlbetrug
schamlose lügen und wahlfälschungen
finden im ganzen land statt die mehrheit
der philippinen fürchtet nicht den
rückfall in eine marcos diktatur
sie sind fasziniert von der idee des
starken mannes
und jetzt erstmal andere nachrichten des
tages von hans bosch die g7 staaten
wollen bei der cyber-sicherheit
intensiver zusammenarbeiten um gemeinsam
den schutz zu verbessern ein zweitägiges
treffen der digitalen minister hat heute
in düsseldorf begonnen der derzeitige
vorsitzende der gruppe bundes digital
und verkehrsminister wissing warnte im
interview mit dem heute-journal update
vorzunehmen der bedrohung durch
russische hacker wegen des krieges in
der ukraine durch diesen krieg habe die
gefahr von cyber-angriffen deutlich
zugenommen so wissing das ganze
interview können sie im heutigen update
gegen 0 uhr sinn oder auf zdf heute.de
bei einer internationalen geberkonferenz
für syrien hat deutschland hilfen von
gut einer milliarde euro angekündigt
insgesamt kamen zusagen in höhe von
knapp 6,4 milliarden euro zusammen auf
einem treffen mit vertretern aus rund 50
ländern machte der eu außenbeauftragte
borel auf die auswirkungen des ukraine
krieges auf syrien aufmerksam 60 prozent
der bevölkerung litten unter
ernährungsunsicherheit bereits jetzt
seien 90 prozent der bevölkerung von
armut betroffen
mit der queen's speech wird in
großbritannien traditionell eine neue
sitzungsperiode von unter- und oberhaus
eingeläutet wegen gesundheitlicher
probleme der queen verlas aber nun
erstmals der britische thronfolger
charles die regierungserklärung
geplant sind unter anderem gesetze um
die folgen steigender
lebenshaltungskosten abzufedern die
zeremonie zählt zu den wichtigsten
konstitutionellen aufgaben der
britischen monarchie
die globale erwärmung könnte schon bis
2026 erstmals über der 15 grad marke
liegen wie die weltwetterorganisation
berichtet liegt die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass dies mindestens in einem jahr
passiert inzwischen bei fast 50 prozent
im pariser klimaabkommen hatte sich die
weltgemeinschaft verpflichtet die
erderwärmung auf möglichst 15 grad im
vergleich zum vorindustriellen zeitalter
zu begrenzen
bundespräsident steinmeier hat seinen
amtssitz von heute an für drei tage nach
sachsen-anhalt verlegt und führt seine
amtsgeschäfte von quedlinburg aus dabei
soll auch zeit für begegnungen und
gespräche seien um zu erfahren was die
menschen bewegt wird limburg ist nach
altenburg in thüringen wo steinmeier im
märz war die zweite station der ortszeit
deutschland
das bundeskriminalamt warnt dass im
vergangenen jahr die zahl politisch
motivierter straftaten einen neuen
höchststand erreicht hat
rechtsextremismus bleibt dabei die
aktuell größte bedrohung aber neu in den
fokus rückt an milieu das sind seiner
gesinnung zwar auch radikal gewaltbereit
antidemokratisch und an team staatlich
ist dass ich aber nicht immer in
traditionelle links rechts schema
einordnen lässt gemeint sind gruppen die
man auch unter kroner leugnern und so
genannten querdenkern finden konnte
gruppen die von event zu event ziehen
man trifft sie als eierwerfer bei
politiker auftritten als masken gegner
die das parlament stürmen wollen oder
als fahnen schwenkende putin freunde und
als gewalttäter die auch vor mord nicht
zurückschrecken henriette de maizière
berichtet
eskalierender protest gegen die kuchener
maßnahmen ganze bevölkerungsgruppen
radikalisiert kommunalpolitiker innen
werden eingeschüchtert wie hier beim
fackelmarsch vor dem wohnhaus der
sächsischen gesundheitsministerin im
vergangenen dezember
beispiele für politisch motivierte
kriminalität die innenministerin warnt
ein ganz wesentlicher teil der taten ist
im zusammenhang mit den protesten gegen
die korona maßnahmen begangen worden
dabei handelt es sich vielfach um
verstöße gegen das versammlungsrecht
beleidigung und bedrohung auch aber
gewaltdelikte wie körperverletzungen das
hinzu der exzessiven gewalttaten dieses
milieu radikalisiert sich passt nicht
mehr in klassische politische kategorien
wie rechts oder links das
bundeskriminalamt spricht von einer
heterogenen mische szene
unterschiedlicher gruppen und personen
was sie eint ist neben der thematik in
weiten teilen auch eine
insgesamt starts kritische bis
staatsfeindliche haltung diese
entwicklung insbesondere vermehrte
angriffe gegen den staat und seine
vertreter gegen abend zum mandatsträger
kaupthing polizisten und medienvertreter
genauso wie die anstiege
fremdenfeindlicher und antisemitischer
straftaten
die müssen wir sie ernst nehmen die
zahlen spiegeln die gesellschaft und die
aktuellen politischen verwerfungen im
land größte bedrohung bleibt wie seit
jahren der rechtsextremismus von dem 40
prozent aller politischen gewalttaten
ausging in einer anschließenden
pressekonferenz kritisieren unabhängige
opferberatungsstellen dass sich die
datenlage nicht klar darstelle leider
müssen wir wie bereits in den vorjahren
auch von einer hohen anzahl nicht
registrierter rechter rassistischer und
antisemitischer gewalttaten sowie von
einer eklatanten unter fassung bei
polizei und justiz ausgeht immer mehr
politisch motivierte extremismus von
rechts und links rassismus und auch
offener antisemitismus der deutlich
angestiegen ist experten befürchten dass
etabliert sich
die gefahr die wir jetzt schon haben ist
eine gewalttätigkeit die im alltag sich
verankert und das ist ein potenzial eine
gefahr mit der man sich ernsthaft
auseinandersetzt muss gerade auch durch
die instabilität mit der wir als
gesellschaft als europa als welt gerade
auch noch mal extra konfrontiert werden
das sind immer schon die sternstunden
von extremen kräften gewesen die
versuchung demokratin anzugreifen die
politisch motivierte kriminalität ist
auf dem höchststand seit der erfassung
corona und der krieg in der ukraine
beschleunigen das noch keine gute
nachricht
und jetzt noch einmal 1 zunächst mit dem
blick auf die finanzmärkte es kommt
immer mehr bewegung in das thema zinsen
es war ist noch unklar wie die
europäische zentralbank angesichts der
hohen inflation ihre zinspolitik
ausrichtet aber weil er die halle unter
anderem bei den sogenannten
negativzinsen tut sich schon etwas ja
zinsen für bankguthaben damit könnte
bald schluss sein denn die erste große
privatbank die ing hat die negativzinsen
für einen großteil ihrer kunden nun
abgeschafft ein paukenschlag
andere banken werden vermutlich folgen
hintergrund ist die banken gehen davon
aus dass die notenbank schon bald die
zinsen anhebt und dann wohl auch die
negativzinsen für banken bei der ezb
wegfielen möglicherweise schon im juni
selbst die sonst zurückhaltende
bundesbank positioniert sich nun da die
inflation im euroraum weiterhin hoch
geht müssen wir handeln meine präferenz
wäre die erste zinsanhebung im
eurosystem im juli dieses jahres zu
haben und tatsächlich galoppiert die
inflation in der eurozone von rekord zu
rekord
im urlaubsland griechenland ist sie im
april auf über zehn prozent geklettert
so hoch wie seit 28 jahren nicht der
staat versucht gegenzusteuern mit
entlastungen für autofahrer und bei den
stromkosten dass die ezb die zinsen
anhebt im juli gilt an der börse schon
fast als ausgemachte sache sparer werden
davon aber erstmal nicht viel merken bis
die banken die sparbuchzinsen
deutlich erhöhen kann es dauern die
bauzinsen jedoch dürften weiter steigen
tun sie jetzt schon und zwar kräftig
walhalla vielen dank
der technologie milliardär elon musk
will die verbannung des früheren us
präsidenten donald trump von twitter
nach der anvisierten übernahme des
kurzbotschaften dienstes rückgängig
machen das sagte er bei einer von der
financial times organisierten konferenz
die entscheidung trump zu verbannen sei
eine moralisch schlechte entscheidung
und einfach nur dumm gewesen so maske
die uefa hat den spielplan für die
fußball-europameisterschaft
2024 in deutschland bekannt gegeben dass
eröffnung spielt mit der deutschen
nationalmannschaft findet am 14 juni in
münchen statt austragungsort für das
endspiel am 14 juli ist berlin
borussia dortmund hat heute bekannt
gegeben dass stürmerstar lingener land
vor einem wechsel zu manchester city
steht hierüber hätten sich alle parteien
dem grunde nach verständigt die
vertraglichen details seien nun noch
abzustimmen ist es in einer mitteilung
und dortmund gab auch eine
spielerverpflichtung bekannt care im
atelier von rb salzburg kommt mit einem
vertrag bis 30 juni 2000 27 zum auftakt
der traditionellen frühjahrs auktionen
ist in new york ein werk des us
künstlers andy warhol versteigert worden
zum rekordpreis es handelt sich um ein
porträt der schauspielerin marilyn
monroe mit rund 185 millionen euro ist
es nun das teuerste versteigerte
kunstwerk des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
die einnahmen aus der versteigerung
sollen laut angaben des vorherigen
eigentümers für wohltätige zwecke
verwendet werden
wer in diesem sommer ein innerdeutsches
ausflugsziel sucht ferropolis die
eiserne stadt in sachsen-anhalt als seit
neuestem eine attraktion mehr ein
aussichtspunkt in luftiger höhe mit
blick über ein gelände das geschichte
atmet die geschichte einer epoche und
einer region und der wandel hagen
nicolas war für uns in ferropolis
das ensemble der riesigen bagger und
kräne beeindruckt auf den ersten blick
es sind letzte zeugen der braunkohle die
die region noch vor einer generation
prägte besucher der stadt aus eisen
bekommen nun eine perspektive hinzu ein
gläserner fahrstuhl führt in 20 metern
höhe auf die erste barrierefreie
aussichtsplattform
ja schon schön also die aussicht ein
bisschen frischer aber ansonsten
war das natürlich ein großer vorzug dass
man das alle hier aufkommen können ja
auch mit kinderwagen school steht dass
man das mal von oben alles sieht
wahnsinn über 20 jahre her da war ich
das letzte mal
hat er keine erinnerung
partyzeit
ferropolis in der internationalen
musikszene längst ein begriff festival
splash und full force zogen vor corona
jährlich zehntausende an zugleich ist
ferropolis ein internationales
industriedenkmal
30 jahre lang ihr der braunkohletagebau
gepaart mit der wiedervereinigung kam
das aus bauhaus studenten lieferten
mitte der 90er jahre die idee die fünf
stahlriesen zu erhalten die landschaft
heute rekultiviert der tagebau zum see
geflutet
diese einmalige industriekultur zu
erhalten ist aufwendig fahrstuhl und
aussichtsplattform am absetzbar zu
errichten eine millioneninvestition
die fördermittel der eigenanteil
reichten einfach nicht mehr die angebote
waren plötzlich 40 prozent über dem was
wir mal kalkuliert hatten guten
gewissens und dann haben wir natürlich
das sanierungskonzept umgestellt und
haben dann selektiv saniert also
wirklich jeden träger jedes stück stahl
abgeklopft und gesagt das kann doch das
hält noch seine zeit das muss erneuert
werden
eine lohnende investition um diese
geschichte auch für die zukunft zu
erhalten rechtzeitig zum beginn der
festivalsaison denn erstmals nach zwei
jahren kehren menschen in die stadt aus
eisen zurück
[Musik]
das was man heute schon mal bei 37 grad
geht es gleich weiter mit seinem thema
das in deutschland mehr als anderthalb
millionen menschen und ihre angehörigen
betrifft demenz die reportage heute
begleitet einen familienvater der diese
diagnose bereits mit mitte 50 bekannt
und gegen 0 uhr gibt es dann unser heute
schon ein update mit wulf schmiese und
uns morgen wieder wir sehen wieder sehen
[Musik]
guten abend morgen zieht ein kleines
tief von großbritannien heran und das
bringt dann an der nordseeküste und in
schleswig holstein auch etwas regen aber
schon heute nacht regnet es leicht dem
südlichen niedersachsen oder auch in
mecklenburg vorpommern
das wird eine sehr lange mainacht mit
tiefsttemperaturen zwischen 17 und 8
grad morgen ziehen über norddeutschland
einige wolken hinweg und die bringen
doch etwas regen mit im süden gibt es
dagegen strahlenden sonnenschein an den
küsten liegen morgen die
höchsttemperaturen so bei 15 bis 18 grad
sonst aber gibt es früh sommerliche
werte zwischen 22 und 30 grad dabei
beginnen morgen die eisheiligen mamertus
pankratius servatius bonifatius und die
kalte sophie dieses jahr fallen die
fröste mitte mai ganz aus seit mitte des
vorigen jahrhunderts kommen sie immer
unregelmäßiger die durchschnittliche
anzahl von frosttagen mitte mai nimmt im
zuge des klimawandels ab
spätfröste sind jedoch viel gefährlicher
als noch vor jahrzehnten
denn pflanzen beginnen zwei bis drei
wochen früher zu blühen spätfröste
können sie vernichten und sind pflanzen
auf bestäubung durch insekten angewiesen
wird doppelt problematisch denn um aktiv
zu werden brauchen bienen mindestens
zwölf grad sonne und beständiges wetter
an sich können sich bienen gut anpasst
bei 1,5 grad globaler temperaturerhöhung
schon 2026 wird allerdings knapp auf
wiedersehen